En VisualPolitik hemos criticado a
Donald Trump más que ningún otro
canal de YouTube.
Sin embargo hay algo en lo que sí tiene
razón.
"Si quieres ser
un ciudadano de méxico
tú y vamos a asumir que eres una
persona perfecta, no te dejarían ser
ciudadana mexicana. Es uno de los lugares
más difíciles para conseguir la
ciudadanía."
En este caso Donald Trump dice la verdad:
México tiene una ley de inmigración
muchísimo más restrictivas que la de
Estados Unidos. Para que se hagan una
idea sólo en el año 2015 el
gobierno mexicano deportó a más de
100.000 inmigrantes ilegales, mientras que
Estados Unidos 300.000. Y sí, sé lo que estáis
pensando: que Estados Unidos todavía
deporta a más gente. Pero ojo, pensad que
México tiene tres veces menos
población y recibe muchos menos
inmigrantes que la primera potencia del
mundo.
Si tenemos esto en cuenta podemos decir
que los mexicanos deportan a
prácticamente todo aquel que entra en
el país a través de las fronteras con
Guatemala y con Belice. O por lo menos
a todos aquellos que deciden quedarse en
el país en lugar de continuar su viaje
hacia los Estados Unidos.
De hecho, ¿os acordáis que hace unas
semanas sacábamos un video hablando
sobre la inmigración en Japón?
Si recordáis os decíamos "y en el país
del sol naciente tienen solamente un
2 por ciento de población extranjera" y
que esoo es muy bajo si lo comparamos
con el resto de países del mundo
desarrollado, ¿verdad? Pues bien la
población inmigrante en México no
llega ni siquiera al 1% y para que os
hagáis una idea mientras el presidente
de México Don Enrique Peña Nieto le
espetaba esto a Donald Trump:
"los mexicanos en Estados Unidos son gente
honesta y trabajadora, son personas de
bien que respetan a la familia que
respetan la vida en comunidad y que
respetan la ley. Como tal los mexicanos
merecen el respeto de todos".
El 48% de la opinión pública mexicana
afirmaba tener una opinión mala o muy
mala
sobre los inmigrantes centroamericanos.
Es más por esas mismas fechas el diario
mexicano La Mañana publicaba este artículo:
"Sí al muro fronterizo, pero en el sur de México".
"El problema que viven México y
Estados Unidos se puede resolver y esto
es con la construcción del muro
fronterizo propuesto por Donald Trump, pero
en el sur para evitar el cruce ilegal de
centroamericanos".
¿Qué? ¿Cómo os quedáis? Hoy
vamos a ver a fondo la ley de
inmigración mexicana. ¿Por qué México
deporta a los centroamericanos?
Lo primero que tenemos que entender
cuando hablamos de inmigración hacia
México es su situación geográfica.
Imaginad que vivís en Nicaragua y
queréis emigrar a los Estados Unidos,
pero que no tenéis ni dinero ni
recursos para compraros un billete de
avión.
Pues bien el único modo para llegar al
país de las oportunidades por vía
terrestre es cruzando México por
carretera y como os podéis imaginar el
mayor flujo de inmigración del mundo es
el que va desde latinoamérica hasta los
Estados Unidos.
Solo en el año 2015 hicieron este viaje
más de 22 millones de personas y se
trata de una ruta peligrosísima por
carreteras en un estado pésimo y
en zonas ultraviolentas. No olvidéis que
estados mexicanos como Chiapas, Guerrero
o Sinaloa son las auténticos epicentros
del narcotráfico.
"Porque sufren todos
los abusos posibles, extorsiones,
secuestros, tráfico de personas, tráfico
de estupefacientes, trata de personas con
fines de explotación laboral y sexual".
Para que os hagáis una idea, muchas de
esas personas que llegan al sur de
México continúan su viaje hacia los
Estados Unidos
subidos en el techo de un tren de
mercancías. A este tren se le conoce con
el sobrenombre de la bestia o el tren de
la muerte. Y ya os podéis imaginar de
dónde viene el nombre.
"Pues también ya
existe el fenómeno del migrante que ya
se queda en México".
Esta situación fue la excusa perfecta
para que en los años 70
el gobierno de México sacara su
llamada Ley General de Población.
Una ley que entre otras muchas cosas
servía para evitar el abuso hacia los
inmigrantes y cosas como la trata de
blancas.
¿El problema? Que lo que en un
principio podría parecer una
motivación noble se convirtió en un
auténtico infierno para los extranjeros.
Y os preguntaréis, ¿qué es lo que hacía
que esta ley fuera tan dura para los
inmigrantes? Para que os hagáis una idea:
esta ley permitía al gobierno
expulsar a los extranjeros por razones
tan peregrinas como ésta:
"la secretaría de gobernación podrá
negar a los extranjeros
la entrada al país o el cambio de
calidad o característica migratoria
cuando lo exija el equilibrio
demográfico nacional".
En otras palabras, México sólo está
dispuesto a recibir a extranjeros que
vengan de países ricos y ser posible
que tengan la piel blanca.
¿El resultado? Siete de cada diez
inmigrantes son estadounidenses y
prácticamente el resto vienen de
España. Es más: hay dos veces más
españoles que guatemaltecos.
Esto no sería ninguna sorpresa si no
fuera porque Guatemala hace frontera con
México y España está a miles de
kilómetros y con una océano de por medio.
Pero no sólo esto es que además
México tiene prácticamente el mismo
número de alemanes que de peruanos.
En otras palabras que si vienes desde
Europa o desde Estados Unidos no vas a
tener ningún problema en conseguir el
visado porque al parecer estás
contribuyendo a favorecer el equilibrio
demográfico.
Ahora bien si estáis viendo este
vídeo desde Perú y queréis emigrar
al país de Chumel Torres...
Lo siento pero vais a tener que buscar
otro país en el que no se os
considere una amenaza demográfica.
Pero no sólo eso, es que con esta ley
ser inmigrante ilegal en México se
consideraba un delito federal.
Eso significa que en cualquier momento y
en cualquier lugar
la policía mexicana podía pararte por
la calle y pedirte los papeles. Y si no
los tenías no sólo te deportaban a tu
propio país sino que además te
obligaban a pagar una multa que
equivalía a dos veces el salario medio
mexicano. Todo esto podría pasar
inadvertido en la comunidad
internacional, a fin de cuentas cada país
es libre de fijar las leyes de
inmigración que quiera. Pero en el año
2010 pasó algo que destaparía las
vergüenzas de toda una nación:
"la gobernadora de Arizona Jan Brewer ha
firmado la ley de inmigración del
estado
considerada una de las más duras de la
nación".
Por irónico que resulte la ley de
inmigración de Arizona pensada para
frenar el tráfico de personas que
venían desde México era
prácticamente un calco de la ley
mexicana. Ahora bien a pequeña escala, porque por
ejemplo aunque este estado considere
que la inmigración ilegal es también
un delito, como no es el gobierno de
Washington
solamente lo puede perseguir dentro de
los límites de lo que es Arizona.
Dicho de otra manera no es un delito
federal de esos que persigue el FBI.
Sin embargo esta ley acaparó la
atención de todos los medios de
comunicación a lo largo y ancho del
mundo y el que por aquel entonces era el
presidente de México Felipe Calderón
no se quedó atrás:
"toda regulación que se centre en
criminalizar el fenómeno migratorio, un
fenómeno social, un fenómeno económico
y criminalizarla de esta manera abre la
puerta a la intolerancia, al odio a la
discriminación al abuso en la
aplicación de la ley".
Con un par de
cojones, sí señor.
A partir de ese momento en algunos
diccionarios aparece la foto de Felipe
Calderón junto a la definición de la
palabra hipocresía.
Lógicamente la reacción internacional
no se hizo esperar y por eso en menos
de un año el gobierno mexicano se vio
obligado a cambiar su Ley General de
Población en la que por fin se
descriminalizaba la entrada ilegal en el
país.
Pero esperad un momento porque
todavía no hemos terminado.
Efectivamente México cambió su ley de
inmigración pero no del todo.
¿Recordáis que os decía que la policía
mexicana podía pedirle los papeles a
cualquier persona que pensara que es un
inmigrante ilegal? Pues es tal cual por
ejemplo en Estados Unidos las
autoridades necesitan tener como mínimo
la sospecha de que ha realizado un
delito para poderte pedir los papeles. Es
decir que no es tan fácil eso de
pararte por la calle y meterse en un
furgón policial.
Sin embargo en México es totalmente
normal por ley: las autoridades no necesitan
tener ninguna sospecha para pedirte los
papeles y si a eso le sumas el poco
control que hay en este país sobre su
propia policía te encuentras con cosas
como ésta:
"para escapar de la deportación algunos
emigrantes pagan mordidas de entre 30 y
300 dólares a los policías".
Pero esperad un momento porque alguno
pensará que el caso de México es un
caso aislado en el mundo, ¿verdad?
Normalmente cuando hablamos de
inmigración siempre nos referimos a
gente que viaja de países
relativamente pobres a esos lugares que
son los más ricos del planeta: Estados
Unidos, Canadá o Europa. ¿Verdad?
Pues lo cierto es que sólo en el año
2015 hubo más de 80 millones de
personas que emigraron de países pobres
a países que eran un poquito más ricos
pero que todavía seguían estando en
vías de desarrollo. Por ejemplo. cada
año hay cientos de miles de personas
que viajan desde Bangladesh hasta la India. Y no penséis que les reciben con
los brazos abiertos precisamente. Y si no
mirad lo que decía el que ahora es
presidente de la india Narendra Modi
durante su campaña electoral:
"lo podéis poner por escrito: a partir
del 16 de mayo los bangladesíes que
viven aquí pueden ir haciendo las maletas".
Todo esto contrasta con esa política
aperturista que tienen en otros países
como Canadá o Nueva Zelanda, que
curiosamente
son dos de los lugares más ricos del
mundo.
Pero, ¿vosotros qué pensáis? ¿Creéis que Estados
Unidos o Europa deberían seguir
el modelo de la India o de México? ¿O tal
vez deberíamos apostar por el modelo
canadiense? En este vídeo os explicamos
por qué en Canadá
apuestan por la cultura de recibir a la
gente con los brazos abiertos. Y por
supuesto no olvidéis que subimos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas, así
que suscribíos al canal para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones.
Si te ha gustado el vídeo dadle a like y
nos vemos en el próximo.
¡un abrazo y hasta pronto!